now why do i like this question for two
reasons uh i said if you were on time
number one and i suppose this is why
it's in an extension section
right uh you really gotta think through
what all your equations mean and even
what equation should you use
at some points in your working it's very
unclear um
so first requires real thought and you
need to practice at that
it's very hard for me to teach it to you
like here's here's a few steps that you
do like the point is that
there aren't steps for it you have to
think on your own and secondly
it's just a really cool result like you
can work out escape velocity
which i know like the point is not that
um
if you want to know escape velocity this
is the process you would go through okay
if you're a real physicist you just look
up the number okay
but the fact that we can get something
like this which is very complicated
right
from very simple maths right we're just
you know 17 years old or something like
that
i think that's kind of neat okay and the
equations that govern are very simple as
well
so let's give this a go where does this
start newton's law of gravitation
says an object falling toward a planet
has this acceleration
now just before i go any further because
i was talking to some year 10s recently
it's on my mind
uh do you remember from variation right
that because i've got that x to the
minus 2
that's really minus k on x squared
right so because that x is on the
denominator
what this is telling us is the force
that's
acting upon this object whatever it is
like in its distance from
earth okay that force
is inversely proportional to the square
of
the distance where the force is coming
from okay uh this is what we were saying
before when i was trying to illustrate
why we're looking at
uh equations in terms of displacement
it's because that's how forces
act in nature okay so that's what we're
looking at
so for some positive constant k and x is
the distance from the center of the
planet
note that by the way um distance from
the center
that'll be important later showing that
if the body starts from rest
at a distance d from the center then
it's speed at
a distance x from the center is such and
such okay right
now in the question sort of tucked away
in all of those sentences there are some
equations
of initial conditions that we want to
get at right
so you can see that last sentence says
if the body
starts okay when you hear the word start
right you say
when t equals zero that's indicating
where you're beginning
right it starts from rest
so that tells us what equation
okay initial velocity is zero and
add a distance d from the center okay so
that's the x value right so don't be
confused there's a lot of letters flying
around
d is just a constant okay you may even
want to write down here right
just to remind you don't substitute
things into d right it's not a variable
you can't change it it's just the
distance you start from
okay now we've got to get towards this
result so what are we going to do
from this where we're going to begin
this equation here you remember we
learnt acceleration on the left-hand
side we can substitute that for a
derivative
namely d on dx or
remember half b squared
okay um yes but they'll totally ask you
to prove it
sometimes okay and that's why i went
through i showed you those two different
ways of proving it
uh and in fact i've got some hsc
practice questions here which we'll get
to
and often the first part is prove this
is equal to acceleration okay if they
don't ask you to prove it you can just
go for it
now that's minus k x to the minus two
okay so left-hand sides in terms of x
right-hand sides in terms of x that's
great let's integrate
so you get half v squared what do i get
on the right hand side when i integrate
minus 2
yeah good it goes up to a minus 1 so it
should be over x so
i'm going to leave that minus k out the
front
that's dividing by x right i've
increased the power by one which means
division
and i have to divide by the new power
is that okay yeah that's it don't forget
your constant
okay so a bit of cancelling here that's
actually k
on x
and we're getting towards an equation
for
speed right speed at a distance x from
the center okay
now this is velocity which is like speed
and one beta so we'll go speed and we'll
know which way it's facing but later on
we can disregard
which direction it's going in so if we
want to get v
let's see what we can do here v squared
is equal to
i'm going to double everything
and now i have a constant to get out of
the way so what am i going to use to
evaluate my constant
right so i've got an x here and a v
and i've got an answer to v here right
so at this particular time those are the
values i've got
right so i will say when
v equals zero x equals
d okay so straight substitution i'm
going to work out what c is
so zero here two k
on d plus my constant okay so
if that's what my constant is i can
bring it back into my equation for v
squared okay
now uh i can tidy up a little bit take
out that common factor
throw a 2k out the front
okay so v squared there
now uh pause and have a look
i want to get speed right and what i've
got is velocity squared okay
so velocity and speed are almost the
same if i square root
yeah plus or minus i can't just
eliminate that
and this square root here
okay i'm missing something oh no i just
have added them together all right
now when you combine these um these two
fractions you get them on the common
denominator that's going to explain
what you see under the square root there
but importantly right
here i've got my equation for v right
but speed disregards direction
okay so i can actually forget about
whether it's plus or minus i can just
say the speed
is um a scalar right so it's just going
to be a positive
quantity because you know we don't say
i'm traveling minus 60 k's an hour if
you're asking for speed you just take
the positive part
okay so i ditched the minus
and then when you take these fractions
together on a common denominator
you should get what is it i think it's d
minus x on dx yeah okay
all right no problems now what's this
this is the equation for speed
given certain initial conditions okay
namely that you start
somewhere off in space okay and then
you're not moving and you drop it
okay so those are the conditions we're
looking at now when you have a look at
question 25
okay it says a projectile is fired
vertically upwards with speed v
from the surface of the earth okay so
think about what that changes about this
question
right in part a for 25 it says assuming
the same equation of motion
right now this is an equation of motion
right
it is one of many okay but it's not
going to be the equation of motion that
stays the same
why not
why why doesn't this hold for the next
question when they said
assume the same equation of motion
where did we get this equation from uh
we got it from
this process of integrating and then
importantly when we're trying to work
out what the constant was okay
we stuck in these initial conditions but
these initial conditions have nothing to
do with question 25
right they're totally different number
one you're not floating off somewhere in
space
number two you're not at rest initially
right you're being fired away from the
earth okay
so therefore i'm going to get a
different set of these which is going to
give me a different value for c
okay so let's start working on that i'm
going to get rid of this